im september 2019 soll die im
regierungsprogramm beschlossene
berufsbildende höhere schule verführung
und sicherheit ihren betrieb aufnehmen
das teilte der generalsekretär des
bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung wolfgang baumann
stellvertretend für
verteidigungsminister kunasek bei einer
pressekonferenz am dienstag den 27
november 2008 10 mit das neue projekt
der sicherheits schule oder gemeinsam
mit dem bildungs der richter von
niederösterreich johann heuras
vizebürgermeister christian stocker
sowie dem kommandanten der
theresianischen militärakademie karl
braun hagel immer wieder saal der down
kaserne präsentiert was wären die
lerninhalte seien in erster linie wollen
wir führung führungsverhalten
risikomanagement gefahren analysieren
analysen an die jungen schüler und
schülerinnen weitergeben
es wird eine öffentlich-rechtliche
schule sein
basierend auf dem auf der grundlage
einer fünfjährigen handelsakademie mit
abschluss matura dazu werden derzeit
zusätzlich zu bereits bestehenden
einrichtungen neue und moderne schul und
internatsgebäude am campus der
militärakademie geplant die neue
öffentlich-rechtliche sicherheits schule
bietet absolventen vielfältige
berufsaussichten als führungskräfte beim
bundesheer polizei oder justiz bis hin
zur jobmöglichkeiten in
sicherheitsrelevanten organisationen wie
eu oder nato
[Musik]